lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre las fuerzas que existen
entre átomos neutros o moléculas neutras
las primeras de estas fuerzas inter
moleculares de las que hablaremos son
las fuerzas de dispersión de london
suena muy elegante pero en realidad es
un fenómeno bastante interesante y casi
intuitivo estamos acostumbrados a pensar
en los átomos digamos que tenemos un
átomo neutro por lo que tiene la misma
cantidad de protones y electrones esos
son todos los protones y los neutrones
en el núcleo entonces tendrá una nube de
electrones me estoy imaginando que todos
estos electrones saltan alrededor así es
como lo voy a representar y esto
definitivamente no está dibujado a
escala ya que el núcleo en realidad
sería mucho más pequeño si lo fuera
imaginemos que hay un átomo adyacente
aquí y también es neutro tal vez es el
mismo tipo de átomo podría ser diferente
pero vamos a decir que es neutro también
tiene una nube de electrones si ambos
tienen una carga neutra como se
atraerían entre sí eso es lo que
explican realmente las fuerzas de
dispersión de london porque hemos
observado que
los átomos neutros y las moléculas
neutras pueden atraerse entre sí la
forma de pensar en esto es que los
electrones están constantemente saltando
de manera probabilística están en esta
densa nube de probabilidad donde un
electrón podría estar en cualquier lugar
en cualquier momento dado pero no
siempre se distribuirán de manera
uniforme pueden imaginar que en algún
momento el átomo izquierdo podría verse
así solo por un momento en el que se
encuentran la mayoría o una buena
cantidad de los electrones en el lado
izquierdo del átomo más que en el lado
derecho tal vez se vea algo así y
durante ese pequeño instante el átomo
tendría una carga negativa parcial
esta es la letra griega delta delta
minúscula que se utiliza para denotar
carga parcial y de este lado podemos
tener una carga positiva parcial
recuerden cuando estaba distribuido de
manera uniforme la carga negativa fue
compensada por la carga positiva del
núcleo pero en el lado derecho ya que
hay menos electrones aquí tal vez sea
parcialmente positiva y en el lado
izquierdo donde está
de los electrones en ese momento sea
parcialmente negativa que podría inducir
esto en el átomo vecino piénsenlo pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en lo que podría
suceder en el átomo vecino bueno sabemos
que las cargas similares se repelen
entre sí y las cargas opuestas se atraen
si tenemos una carga positiva parcial
aquí en el lado derecho de este átomo
izquierdo entonces los electrones
negativos de este átomo derecho podrían
ser atraídos hacia él entonces estos
electrones de aquí podrían cargarse un
poco hacia la izquierda eso inducir a lo
que se llama un dipolo ahora tenemos una
carga negativa parcial en el lado
izquierdo de ese átomo y por lo tanto
una carga positiva parcial en el lado
derecho del mismo ya teníamos un dipolo
aleatorio en el átomo izquierdo y eso ha
inducido un dipolo en el átomo derecho
un dipolo es justo cuando tenemos la
separación de carga cuando tenemos las
cargas positivas y negativas en dos
partes diferentes de una molécula o un
átomo o realmente cualquier cosa en este
ejemplo de repente estos dos personajes
eran atraídos entre sí o los átomos se
atraerán entre sí y esta atracción que
se produce debido a los polos inducidos
es exactamente de lo que tratan las
fuerzas de dispersión de london en
realidad podemos llamar a las fuerzas de
dispersión de london fuerzas dipolo
inducido dipolo inducido se sienten
atraídos entre sí porque lo que puede
comenzar como un desequilibrio temporal
de electrones induce un dipolo en el
otro átomo o la otra molécula y luego
ambos se atraen en la siguiente pregunta
que pueden hacer es que tan fuertes
pueden llegar a ser estas fuerzas esto
tiene que ver con la noción de polaris
habilidad que tan fácil es polarizar un
átomo o una molécula en términos
generales cuantos más electrones
tengamos o cuanto mayor sea la nube de
electrones que generalmente se asocia
con la masa molar entonces mayor será la
polar y zabi lidad porque participarán
más electrones si esto fuera sólo un
hidrógeno en el que tenemos un electrón
las probabilidades de que tengamos un
desequilibrio grave en cualquier momento
son bajas a lo sumo tendremos un electro
en un lado en lugar de en el otro pero
podemos imaginar una situación con un
átomo más grande o una molécula más
grande que tenga una nube de electrones
más grande y que de repente tenga un
desequilibrio donde haya muchos
electrones en el lado izquierdo lo que
puede crear un dipolo temporal bastante
importante que luego podría inducir a su
vez un dipolo razonablemente
significativo en una molécula vecina y
esto podría tener un efecto dominó en
toda la muestra de esa molécula por
ejemplo si comparamos algunos gases
nobles entre sí podemos ver los gases
nobles aquí en el lado derecho si
comparamos las fuerzas de dispersión de
london entre por ejemplo el helio y el
argón cual creen que tendría mayores
fuerzas de dispersión de london un grupo
grande de átomos de helio o un gran
grupo de átomos de argón bueno los
átomos de argón tienen una nube de
electrones más grande por lo que tienen
una mayor polarizada
lo que resulta en mayores fuerzas de
dispersión de london de hecho podemos
ver esto en sus puntos de ebullición
para el helio el punto de ebullición es
4.6 grados celsius
para el argón el punto de ebullición es
igual a 80 y 7.5 grados celsius una
forma de pensar en esto es que se
necesita mucho más calor mucha más
temperatura para que el argón pase de un
estado líquido a un estado gaseoso que
para el helio porque es eso bueno eso se
debe a que las moléculas de argón
vecinas tienen fuerzas de dispersión de
london más altas se sienten más atraídas
entre sí están induciendo dipolos más
fuertes entre sí por lo que se necesita
más energía para que se liberen unas de
otras y entren en un estado gaseoso y
las moléculas en términos generales
cuanto más grande sea la molécula debido
a que tiene una nube de electrones más
grande tendrá mayor polariza bilidad y
mayores fuerzas de dispersión de london
pero también la forma de las moléculas
es importante
cuanto más puedan entrar en contacto las
moléculas entre sí cuanto mayor sea el
área superficial que tengan expuesta
mayor será la probabilidad de que puedan
inducir estos dipolos entre ellas por
ejemplo el butano puede presentarse en
dos formas diferentes una que se conoce
como n
que se ve así tiene 4 carbonos y 10
hidrógenos 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 esto se
conoce como n butano otra forma de
butano conocida como hizo butano se
vería así tenemos 3 carbonos en la
cadena principal y luego tenemos un
carbono que se desprende de ese carbono
de en medio y todos tienen 4 enlaces los
enlaces sobrantes se podría decir tienen
hidrógenos entonces se vería así esto es
hizo butano ahora si tenemos una muestra
de un montón de n butano en comparación
con una muestra de un montón de hizo
butano cuál de estos creen que tendrá un
punto de ebullición más alto pausa en el
vídeo y piensen en esto bueno si tenemos
un montón de n butano uno al lado del
otro imaginemos otro n butano justo aquí
tendrá más área superficial para sus
butanos vecinos porque es una molécula
larga puede exponer esta superficie de
sus vecinos mientras que él hizo butano
de alguna manera es un poco más compacto
en menos superficie no tiene estas
grandes cadenas largas debido a que
tenemos estas moléculas de n butano más
largas tendrán mayores fuerzas de
dispersión de london estos obviamente
tienen la misma cantidad de átomos
tienen la misma cantidad de electrones
por lo que tienen nubes de electrones de
tamaño similar tienen la misma masa
molar pero debido a la forma alargada de
n butano pueden acercarse más unos a
otros e inducir más de estos y polos
simplemente observando la forma del n
butano con respecto al isobutano
diríamos que las fuerzas de dispersión
de london son más altas en el n butano
por lo que tendrá un punto de ebullición
más alto se necesitará más energía para
superar las fuerzas de dispersión de
london y entrar en un estado gaseoso